bonsoir et bienvenue pour le 7 8 sur tv
fil 78 il est 18 heures si vous nous
suivez en direct en ce 28 février nous
allons revenir sur l'actualité locale au
cours de la prochaine heure et voici
tout de suite les titres en images
quelques sujets qui nous allons
développer les chiffres du chômage ne
sont pas bons dans les yvelines l'emploi
temporaire est aussi à la baisse une
baisse qui s'accélère par rapport à la
moyenne nationale
un secteur par contre qui ne connaît pas
à la crise c'est lee commerce certains
ont même fait ce choix comme cette
petite boutique en ligne d'accessoires
pour motards basée à montigny le
bretonneux
elle emploie 12 salariés elle s'appelle
eliette daudet et sophie totti lutte et
elles sont toutes les deux
restauratrices elles sont actuellement
au petit soin pour un salon du 19e
siècle au musée national de port royal
des champs à magny les hameaux
le salon qui sera présentée au public en
mai 2013
le handicap et le monde de l'art et unis
un spectacle a été proposé à maurepas
intégralement réalisées par des
résidents en situation de handicap d'un
foyer médicalisé des longs cours et en
plateau justement pour en parler au
début de cette édition philippe
tranchant et vient du biarnès mon soir à
tous les deux ans un des directeurs et
chefs de service de ce foyer d'accueil
médicalisé d'elancourt et vous allez
nous accompagner sur ces premières
minutes du 7-8 vous avez mené pendant 18
mois ce projet on verra l'aboutissement
c'était hier soir du côté de la salle
albert camus à maurepas également à
cette table claire cambier bonsoir ça la
chronique de l'économie en seconde
partie d'édition exactement dans cette
chronique nous parlerons e-commerce un
secteur qui se porte bien
on comptabilise 45 milliards d'euros de
ventes sur internet en 2012 en france
et quand on voit le climat morose ces
temps ci ça fait aussi plaisir de parler
des secteurs qui fonctionne on
retrouvera donc sur ce plateau le
directeur de coûts fils box une société
dit commerce qui vend des boîtes de
confiseries et le président fondateur
d'i graal un site spécialisé dans le
cash back
c'est à dire pour chaque article acheté
chez un commerçant partenaire une partie
du prix d'achat revient à l'acheteur des
bonnes nouvelles donc dans la page
économique
on espère que l'invité viennent avec des
bonbons aussi soudain c'est ce qu'ils
vont pratiquer à toute allure clair la
chronique de l'est
nomi dans une demie en déjà cette
information politique pour débuter elle
concerne l'ump la réintégration de
philippe brillault le maire du chesnay
olivier delaporte sur le maire de la
celle saint cloud et d'olivier de la
sphère conseiller général des yvelines
les trois hommes avaient été suspendus
par les instances nationales de leur
parti pour ne pas avoir respecté les
consignes lors de différents scrutins
souviens par exemple les d'olivier de la
porte il avait maintenu sa candidature
aux législatives l'an dernier malgré l
investiture donner à henri guaino il
avait d'ailleurs dénoncé ce parachutage
le maire du chesnay parle aujourd'hui
d'une logique respectée de tensions
apaisées pourvu que toutes les
sensibilités puissent s'exprimer nous at
il dit récemment des choix on s'en doute
annonciateur des municipales qui se
prépare pour mars 2014 et municipales
justement de son côté le secrétaire
départemental de l'ump jean françois
raynal a décidé de retirer sa
candidature à poissy laissant ainsi la
place libre à karl olive elle conseiller
général les deux hommes étaient en
concurrence pour tenter de récupérer la
ville face au socialiste frédérik
bernard karl olive affiche il est vrai
de nombreux soutiens pour obtenir
l'investiture ce qui n'était pas le cas
de jean françois raynal et pour tout
savoir des municipales téléphiles vous
donne rendez-vous à partir du 9 mars
chaque mois le deuxième samedi du mois
mai une nouvelle émission politique
proposé par la rédaction invités
reportages et débats à tout juste un nom
du scrutin on s'intéresse donc pour
débuter cette édition handicapés à cette
initiative du foyer d'elancourt le
dépassement de soi au théâtre